[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره لهم الانبار من العرب
ذكرت صحيفه التلغراف اللدني انا بريطانيا
تعتزم اعلان الحرس ثوري الايراني رسميا كن
منظمه ارهابيه خلال الاسابيع المقبله ومن
الخطوه تلقى دعم وزراء الامن والداخليه
يعني تجريب الانتماء للحرس الثوري او
المشاركه في اجتماعاته او رفع شعاراته في
بريطانيا وفقا للتقرير ياتي هذا الاجراء
بعد اكثر من 10 مؤامرات في الحرس الثوري
الايراني لاختطاف او قتل اشخاص في
بريطانيا خلال العام الماضي
طلبت منظمه العفو الدوليه ايران بيوقف
فوري لحكم الاعدام مصادر بحق المتظاهره
شابه محمد برغني والغاء العقوبه الصادره
بحقه المنظمه دانت ايضا قرار المحكمه
العليا بايران تاييده حكم الاعدام مصادر
ضمن على خلفيه الاحتجاجات ووصفت محاكمته
امام القضاء سوري
في المدن الايرانيه احرقوا صورا لقاسم
سليمان وذلك في عشيه الذكر الثالثه لمقتله
اردني
يعقد الاتحاد الاوروبي واوكرانيا قمه في
كيف في الثالث فبراير المقبل لمناقشه
الدعم الماليه والعسكري حسب ما اعلن مكتب
الرئيس
تفاصيل هذا الاجتماع مع رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
في اول مكالمه هاتفيه يجريها هذا العام
واضاف البيان ان الطرفين اتفقنا على تكثيف
العمل التحضيري لهذه القمه كما تحدث
الجانبان عن توريد اسلحه مناسبه
وتطرقا لبرنامج مساعدات ماليه جديد بقيمه
18 مليار يورو ليكرا
اعلانات
عن هجوم بكير الذي تسبب بمقد ليلي 78 مجند
روسيا بحسب ما تحدثت مصادر موليه لروسيا
في دوناتس وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت
بدورها عند الهجوم الذي استهدف معسكر
تجنيد مؤقت في ماكيكا
63 شخصا كما قال بصله
بعض السماح للمجندين في معسكر التدريب
باستخدامه هواتهم
احداثيات مواقع المجندين بعد استخدامهم
الهواء
ضربه اوكرانيه دقيقه وموجعه ودميه قتل
وجرحى من الجنود الروسي
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 63 جنديا لكن كيف تقول
ان العدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
الهجوم وقع في شرق اوكرانيا تحديدا بمدينه
مكيفكه شرقي دونيتسك التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا
اربعه صواريخ مارس ضربت مركزا انتشار مؤقت
للجيش الروسي في المدينه العمليه العسكريه
نفذت بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
تقول مصادر مواليه في دونيتسك ان استخدام
المجندين الروس الواصلين للتو الى المعسكر
لهاتفهم المحموله وبكثافه سمح للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي خطا
روسي فادح وقاتل سبق ان تكرر في حرب
اوكرانيا فالقوات تعتمد بشكل متكرر على
اجهزه اتصالات وخطوط غير امنه او مؤمنه
كالهواتف المحموله واجهزه الراديو التي
تعمل بنظام الضغط للتحدث الهجوم الاخير
يعكس قدرا كبيرا من التقدم الاوكراني في
الحرب الالكترونيه بفضل مكياج بمعدات
غربيه متطوره
بحسب خبراء فان اوكرانيا استفاده من
الاتصالات الروسيه نفسها وحجزت اشارتها
واعمت رقابتها واستولت على بعض انظمه
الحرب الالكترونيه الاكثر تقدمها لكن ثم
من يرى ان القاده الروس العسكريين اخطاوا
حين افترضوا ان الجيش الاوكراني لم يتطور
كثيرا منذ عام 2015
كما اخطاوا حين تجاهلوا تاثير المعدات
الغربيه وتدريب النيكل الوحدات الاخرانيه
غير ان القيود الروسيه وهراميتها العسكريه
جديده المركزيه اسهمت في ابطال قواتها
باتخاذ قرارات ميدانيه سريعه ومستقله امر
حولها الى اهداف سهله امام وحدات اوكرانيه
اكثر استقلاليه وان كانت اقل عددا وعتادا
يتهم روسيا بالتخطيط منذ فتره طويله
لتنفيذهابات بالطائرات المسيره بهدف
استنزافي اوكرانيا
قوات بلاده وانظمه الدفاعيه المضاد
للطائره
ومن المحتمل ان يكون الهدف من وراء ذلك
وقطاع الطاقه لدينا نحن نتصرف ونفعل
بوسعنا لافشالهم من تحقيق اهدافهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتابع ولكن بعد الفاصل
رونالدو يصل الى الرياض وسط تفاعل سعودي
كبير بعد انضمامه لنادي النصر
اهلا بكم من جديد ذكر المرصد السوري الى
حقوق الانسان ان دوريه من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه نفذت عمليه مبنيه بدعم قوات
التحالف الدولي في دير الزور
من التحالف الدولي
تسليما انفسهم عبر مكبرات الصوت
من خطوره الاقتراب
لا تخفي دوار استراتيجيه وامنيه في
اسرائيل قلقها من امكانيه ان تشهد العلاقه
مع البيت الابيض توتورات على خلفيه هيمانه
وزراء متطرفين على اجنده حكومه نتنياهو
الجديده ويقود ذلك في حال انفجار الوضع مع
الفلسطينيين الى زعزعه الدعم الامريكي
التلقائي الذي تتمتع به اسرائيل منذ عقود
حتى فيما يتعلق بمواجهه الملف الايراني
وما يحمله من تهديدات بنظره اسرائيل
لا تغير ينتظروا في سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بخصوص استمرار
الغارات على ما تسميه اسرائيل التموضع
الايراني في سوريا او مواجهه المشروع
النووي
الايرانيات سد دوائر امنيه واستراتيجيه
اسرائيليه من ان يقود وجود متطرفين في
الحكومه الى اشعال مواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
ما قد يؤثر على العلاقه مع الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيه حتى في التعاون على
مواجهه ايران
لعمليه التي تحدثنا عنها والتي نحذر منها
عمليه تهديد الدعم الامريكي الاوتوماتيكي
لاسرائيل على المدى الطويل واحتمال المس
بالعلاقات الخاصه مع الامريكيين وفي
الخلفيه انتقادات الديمقراطيين اياها
ورغم ان اسرائيل اجرد مناورات فرديه واخرى
مشتركه مع الامريكيين ودول اخرى حاكه
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه الى ان
القدره العسكريه علشان هجوم اسرائيليا
منفرد لم تكتمل بعد معضله اسرائيل ان
استراتيجيتها باتت عالقه منعت الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لكن بدون وجود خطه دوليه
او حتى اسرائيليه جاهزه بينما تهرب طهران
نحو القنبله النوويه تخصيدا لليورانيوم
جوهريا بين الاداره الامريكيه وهمم
اسرائيل في نظاره الى الملف الايراني والى
طريقه التعامل مع هذا التهديد علاقه
نتنياه الفاتره باداره بعيد وتشكيكه فيها
بتاكيده مؤخرا فقط بانه لن يشاركها امر
الضربه لا خشيه من تسريب الامر لمنعها قد
يترك اسرائيل وحدها في المواجهه الى حد
كبير تم ادراك استراتيجيه في اسرائيل بان
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه يحتاج
دعما وتسليح نوعيا امريكيا لتنفيذه بنجاح
والا فان التلويحه بالضرب يصبح تلويحا
بمسدس فارغ من الطلقه زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
معمر الاريانين نابليشا الحوثي تصاعد من
حملات الاعتقال وملاحقه الاعلاميه
والصحفيين في بلاد
عبر حسابه على تويتر ان اعتقال الحوثيين
والصحفيين يؤكد حاله الهستوريه التي اتابد
قياداتهم بعد ارتفاع الى اصوات المناديه
بانتفاضه شعبيه ضد الميليشيا وطالبه
الوزير اليمنيه المجتمع الدولي باداره هذه
الممارسه ممارسه ضغط حقيقي على قيادات
الجماعه لاجبارها على اطلاق سراح كافه
المحتجزين من اعلاميين وصحفيين دون قيد
في تونس شدد الرئيس قيس سعيد في لقاء مع
رئيسه الوزراء على ضروره استمرار عمل
المرافق العموميه والتصدي لكل من يسعى الى
ضربه الاجتماعيه في البلاد ونقلت رئاسه
التونسيه عن صعيد قوله انه لا وجود لاحد
فوق القانون
محاضره من ان اجهزه الدوله لن تبقى مكتوبه
الايدي امام كل من يحاول المساسه بها
دي محطه الجمهوريه بتونس العاصمه وجد كمال
نفسه ينتظر ساعات توال عنه يظهر بوسيله
نقل تقله الى منزله حيث زوجته المريضه
بانتظاره امل كمال في ايجاد وسيله نقل
عموميه تلاشى فلا الحافلات ولا المتر
الخفيف يشتغل بسبب اضراب عمال شركه نقل
تونس
المتزامن مع اضراب سائق التكسي الفرديه
حلول
البعض يلهث وراء وسيله نقل خاصه وخير
البعض الذهاب الى العمل او الدراسه مشيا
على الاقدام وسط حاله من الغضب والاحتقال
لفمه لا نقل ثم حتى شيء صدقني شيء اسف وشي
حزن ولدي هنا واحده من نيتها تونس معنيه
نصف المروج هفضل تونس خمت منكم على بعضهم
يمشي يمشي
لمده شهرين
ويكشف الاضراب المصاحب الماليه التي
تواجهها الشركات العامه التي توشك على
الافلاس بينما تعاني الحكومه اسوا ازمه
الماليه
في حركه النقل وسط العاصمه وتزامن مع
اضراب اصحاب التاكسي الفرديه وهو ما خلف
حاله من الاحتقان لدى التونسيين الذين
تقطع فيهم سبل وزادت معاناتهم وليد
عبدالله العربيه
في السودان وهو برعايه نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقاليه لفريق اول محمد حمدان
دجله تم التوقيع بمحليه بليل بولايه جنوب
دارفور على وثيقه وقف العدايات بين قبيلتي
الداجو ورزيقات
التزامهما بتنفيذ بنود الوثيقه فتح صفحه
جديده من التسامح وعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه
بين قبيلتين الى سابق عهدها وتعهد نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده بحمايه الوثيقه وحفظ
الامن والاستقرار واستكمال تحقيقات وصولا
الى الجنيه وتقديمهم للعداله
اعلنت البحريه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
وسط ابو عاره نساء في افغانستان بعد قيود
طالبان من العمل والتعليم موعد طالبات
افغانيات العربيه كيف تحكمت الانظمه على
مدى العقود الاربعه الماضيه في المراه
وصلبتها حقوقها ويستخدمت قضاياها ورقه
سياسيه بيد الجماعات السلطه
صالحه تخرجت من جامعه كابول قبل 35 عاما
في عهد الرئيس الاسبق نجيب الله تقول انها
وزميلاتها كنا يدرسن في فصول مشتركه مع
الفتيان في وقت كانت الحريه تسود الاجواء
التعليميه ان ذلك وخاصه زي الفتيات
العليا كما كانت المراه تستطيع ان تختار
تخصصها في جميع المجالات المتاحه دون ان
يتوائم
اما شقيقه صالحه فقد التحقت بجامعه كابول
بعد عامين من صالح ولكنها لم تستطع مواصله
الدراسه جراء ظروف عسكريه تضيف ان المراه
الافغانيه قد ظلمت قديما وحديثا بدرجات
مختلفه
الاجتماعيه
فقد تم القضاء على عمليه دراستهن وتدريسهن
في البلد
التي تخرجت منها صالحه اكبر واشهر جامعه
في افغانستان والتي تم تاسيسها سنه
1930 ميلاديه قدمت الالاف من الخريجات في
تخصصات مختلفه الى المجتمع الافغاني
المسيره الطويله في رحله تعليم الفتيات لن
تتوقفها فالمجتمع الافغاني وعلى الرغم من
الازمات المتلاحقه تظل رغبه الافغاني
بمستقبل افضل يكون فيه التعليمه حجر
الزاويه عبد القادر العربيه كابول
يا بابا رفيع في اداره الرئيس بوينت كوريا
الشماليه بالقيام
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
مشتركه مع كوريا الجنوبيه
قبل ذلك دفر رئيس الامريكيه جوبا ايضا ان
تكون الولايات المتحده بصدد مناقشته اجراء
تدريبات نوويه مشتركه مع كوريا الجنوبيه
وناقضا تصريحات نظيره الكوريه الجنوبي
وكان رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه قال في وقت سابق
نبيل هذا هو واشنطن تناقشان امكانيه تنظيم
تدريبات المشتركه باستخدام القدرات
النوويه
جاءت هذه التصريحات بعد دعوه يوم الى
الاستعداد للحرب بقدرات ساحقه بعد عام شهد
عددا قياسيا من تجارب اطلاق الصواريخ من
كوريا
وصل اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض برفقه عائلته
تمهيدا للمشاركه مع النصر السعودي وينتظر
ان يقدم النادي لاعبه الجديد الى الجماهير
اليوم في ملعب مرسول بارك وسطى حضور
جماهيري ويعلمي كبير من داخل السعوديه
وخارجها من المنتظر ان يلقى كريستيانو
رونالدو خلال حفله التقديم يلقي كلمه
يخاطب بها جماهير هذه
الجريمه
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو الى النادي
العاصميه حتى بدات الانذار تتجه الى
المتجر الرسمي لنادي النصر وهذا احد
المناظر ل- اا مشجعين فرحين جدا بالحصول
على
تيشيرت كريستيانو رونالدو في المتجر
الرسمي الذي تباع فيه همم
والتيشرتات الخاصه بكريستيانو
رونالدو بالاضافه الى المتجر الرسمي هنالك
متجر الكترونيه بيع في هذا التيشيرت
لكريستيانو رونالدو بدءا من صفقه الانتقال
من اعلانها مباشره تم وضع عدد من
الفانيلات الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو لمع
نادي النصر الا انها نفذت بشكل كامل
فبالتالي يتم الاستعانه
بطريقه اخرى
لتوفير هذا التيشيرت للمشجعين باسرع وقت
ممكن الطريقه اخرى ان ياتي المشجع مباشره
ويشتري تيشيرت او فانيلا بدون رقم وبدون
اسم اي لاعب بعد ذلك ينتقل الى المرحله
همم الثانيه وهي مرحله الطباعه وفيها
يتواجد عدد من موظفي المتجر الرسمي ويطبع
اسم كريستيانو ورقمه مباشره ليستلمها
المشجع برضافه الى تواجد الموقع همم
الالكتروني الذي توفر في التيشيرتات قريبا
ولكن حتى الان همم لم يتم توفير عدد كبير
من التيشرتات وهي ليست متوفره حتى هذه
اللحظه الكثير من الجماهير يطالبون
بتوفيرها باقرب همم لحظه و بعدد ضخم من
الارقام لكي يتسنى لكل محبي ومشجعين
كريستيانو رونالدو الحصول على هذا
التيشيرت وهمم
وشرائه مباشره سواء من متجر الكترونيه
وحتى من متجر النادي عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه الرياض
هو في الختام هذا التذكيره بابرز العالم
لندن تعتزم وتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه وحظره جميع نشاطاته على الاراضي
البريطانيه
قمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه مرتقبه مطلع
فبراير تيم روسيا بسرعه
كوريا الجنوبيه
لعيبه النصر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]